yeah hello welcome to this video I'm
trying out something new playing a
computer here stop fish I never ate only
chess dork
yeah not a very regularly chess user so
I'm hope I hope I'm not screwing things
up by doing something wrong yeah stop
fish is set on level 8 and supposedly
it's 2400 on that level so let's see
what we what we get I'm playing on
trying to play a little bit of entire
computer stuff sure don't usually do
this kind of opening but computer
sometimes doesn't handle this so well so
I hope to catch the Machine a little bit
of God the time control is eight minutes
base time and five-second increment you
really have to do it with increment
otherwise the computer has or the
computer's advantage is just too high in
being able to play moves without any
time spent okay a computer played c4
which in general I welcome that the
position is closed I wonder if I should
try something like before and 84 to
completely close it down I'm not sure if
I can manage that b3 b5 b3 b5 a4 b4 it's
something that the computer probably can
play not sure about it it looks rather
logical to play like this a4 b4 Queen c2
I don't think that should be too bad for
me yeah the engine is playing instant
moves as usual the computers some are
programmed that way so Quincy - I guess
hope that is okay yeah Knight takes on
if it takes on c3 yeah I have to check
with the Queen I guess let's see 6
interesting so what's happening here
Knight might come to a 5 c4 doesn't seem
to be doing much we are probably just
developing I'm just not sure where to be
five with the bishop and Lisa took the
temples Knight a5 queen bee - I guess
queen bee - I was thinking yeah now I'm
going back maybe the computer can play
b3 now no well I didn't expect that one
what is the point here if I am taking
things 95 this also owed someone in
there I don't quite get it if I take on
c4 with the knight Knight c4d takes
bishop takes what is the tactic Queen a5
maybe I don't know
what is the point he cannot go Queen c7
I said Bishop on f4 feels like I'm
overlooking stuff but I don't see what
it is
Queen takes Knight before is this so
dangerous I have to check with the Queen
that much is clear I cannot allow that
pawn to stay there well maybe I can
actually but why can I not take on c3
not sure don't see it okay so there is
no like big reason so cancellous I guess
can take on f3 but
well nothing to do about that okay so
what about this position I'm a pawn up
that's nice I have to take though I
cannot allow Knight f4 so I have to take
this and now black has slight
compensation I guess f3 is hanging yeah
I probably have to cover it I just
wonder with what exactly
if or before that's queen h5 I guess I
did kind of weakens a little bit my
position we are king
Kim G - looks safer I have to also have
an eye about
you have to look at we have a look at
the clock so go here attacking a six and
now rooks III maybe maybe you really
want to go look see one here and stay
active not defending passively but he
can take and take a form which is really
annoying
maybe Queen b3 yeah Queen b3 off to
Queen B seven okay that I don't
understand 22 maybe as this idea or its
idea yeah I will definitely make that
mistake calling the computer he which is
yeah nothing to do I cannot do anything
about it so I'm trying to say okay let's
do this I have Lucas e2 to cover that
okay I didn't see that more coming not
at all
but it's not such a big deal probably I
cannot take because of Queen d2 and but
he doesn't have a check here right so if
I play Queen c3 the computer has to
trade then I'm winning a tempo and I can
invade with the rook so that position is
at least around equal and probably it is
is even somewhat better for wide let's
see oops e6
I'm going back try to win a champion or
sure
maybe rook c6 uh-huh comes like that
okay I can try 8:45 I think I will do
that
d5 I can also play then these six maybe
maybe the King King first I need to I
need the King definitely okay so the
comp is not doing much here
so d5 now or not now looks very logical
to do that I can also go to the rook
endgame that also is pretty nice hmm
difficult it's tough to say if I should
do the rook and game or not but he can
also it can also go to e 8 so let's push
the pawn up removin okay um King before
I guess the engine is a lot a lot ahead
on the clock yeah rooks e7 that's the
most normal move here maybe I can go
Bishop c7 which should be six Bishop c5
check it might be an idea let's do that
look see India now I'll go here and
intending Bishop c5 yes but if I do that
now okay but I can't go rook c7 which
should be quite good I mean I have King
c4 King b5 coming it's definitely better
for white I'm not quite sure if I can
win this is the real issue ship c5 is
also pretty strong but let's do that
it's simple it's the keep it simple
method where am I going though this is
an interesting question all the way back
on Bishop to b6 and directly
yes King D six this is irritating me
quite a bit
if I can if I go to Gees rear and then
you see for b5 I have a hard time sure
to get them it's very likely a draw
unfortunately it says some way to win
king b5 King d5 Bishop f5
say anything better can I somehow
windows in some way windows porn without
giving up giving up t5 I don't see it we
should back here Bishop g3 checking
before I don't get the porn so let's do
this and trade Wow that I didn't expect
I was thinking that it should okay maybe
it's a draw I'm that's possible that
computers quick enough here to to draw
but I don't see it it just gets in G for
now okay I take this when H for it's
there some way to screw it up not really
okay yeah so it's it's a draw at the end
that's cheeky okay come on take it okay
so the first game is a draw let's
continue and see what happens to a
rematch so what's what's up now that was
nice I definitely had some some
opportunities there I don't see a match
- I thought that ditches also always had
a match score somewhere here
I don't give 15 seconds now okay what am
I going to do I'm going to go be 5 as I
usually do and see what the comp is
doing
okay we've got exchanged
yeah so it will be will be some kind of
endgame Bishop g4 is the line that most
with the biggest probability leads to an
endgame
do you three is a bit uncommon okay I
think I'm going to protect this and now
go c5 to make sure that d4 is not
happening so push about 97 oh it's very
normal
Oh engine is really shutting it down
no it's not oops what c4 really is a
terrible really terrible but before it's
the way to justify it I had to go b6
yeah of course I cannot take because of
c5 and b6 looks really ugly okay so I
have to play play this opponent down
it's not not sure how terrible it is
maybe I have some opportunities iam
still
Quincy a truck t8 maybe something like
that that's still not not super easy for
white
yeah not easy for me to go before or
something like that
that queen is sick so I can just stay I
really have no particular idea here
before yeah just not it's not much fun
quite obviously hmm it's f5 a movie or
is this completely ridiculous
f5 Teague's Queen takes and I probably
even g4 ISM and I can take on d3 no I
cannot
um okay
can i double on the default somehow b7s
week always
Jim let's let's do that still it's not
not quite clear what's what the next
plan is for for him or for it may be
here yeah at one point this this this
would this is kind of necessary at one
point okay you know here it's no
question I have to take and now b7 is
hanging if I go rook b8 there is C six
so I probably have to take C five cannot
go C 6 rupee eight again it's not
working yeah so I have to take this and
play this position which is not great
it's especially not great against the
computer against the human being I
wouldn't be that pessimistic because
it's what still has a couple of
weaknesses but the computer usually is
very strong at keeping keeping those at
bay okay yeah what it takes here didn't
expect that which doesn't mean much I
mean okay anyway it's not it's not that
easy I stole this count to play against
you three
I just blundered there
I said I just I just blended this bone
okay
hmm any any counter flame
no not really
TRADD she gets near the king but that's
not really happening queen g600 can't
see fine thanks
I can actually draw here okay I can
resign that now that was bad that was
bad I overlooked that before move how to
a result actually hear him yeah over at
c4 was really bad by what but I have to
go b6 or something okay so let's try
with this kind of thing g3 this kind of
opening also served me well against
engines so we're probably going to go to
a close Catalan I am came computer just
this okay I want to want a pawn back
yeah I really want to go deform so loop
t1 then d4 is the point how do I get
down
wonder if b3 is a move
it's not so easy to get in d4 in the
first place
so yeah computer might even play e5 and
totally totally stop that
mm that's not so it's not nice not easy
to develop maybe just be three or so I
don't like the idea of him playing you
fire him but it happens that looks a lot
like some kind of more oxy point which I
really hate to play against I mean how
did that happen how did that happen
yeah I'm just worse why it's just worse
in this position that's very strange
I somehow missed the right moment to get
in get in that key for move I have to
cover like g4 phones and things I mean
it's not like I'm lost or anything it's
just that I absolutely dislike this
position this position type so what now
something can I do something here
yeah badly need dinner it seems hmm
sorry for the stomach noises so what
happens here I would like to treat
Queens here on c4 yeah maybe I can if it
if yeah
computer computer actually once or
totally allows that that's surprising
okay so I mean both me both recap just
make sense let's do this okay my night
is not great but and I want to make sure
that the night is not invading so let's
do this
Wow conscious trades everything I did
not expect that
what about g4 and then f3 yes maybe okay
Bishop c7 to e5
maybe around the corner and maybe Bishop
e5 my knight really needs to be
activated
okay it says control some some squares
okay I'm checking and go with you five
yep
not much happening here okay if I take
now I have the draw yeah it's it's
difficult to not take on so let's take
so yeah this is a this is a dead wrong
can I offer a draw why Cannot the
computer computer is probably set to
decline the draw yeah it's just a total
fortress
maybe we can I claim somehow it seems to
be oh interesting gigs no okay the
computer also wouldn't blunder yeah this
is kind of clear so I can safely ignore
on that
age five not yet it really is I really
shouldn't even try to do something it's
just a complete draw yeah it seems some
there is no way of really so okay now at
least I know it's it's 50 moves to make
you can very safely pre move
that's a bit stupid
come on yeah anyway hmm it's a bit of a
shame I think the comedy should be set
up in a way that in this kind of
situation it somehow recognizes the draw
I don't know how exactly you would
program that but I didn't I mean
probably this drawing button will be in
effect again once um we have the 50
moves completed I think you so probably
have to claim
oh yeah that's a three-fold repetition
okay claim a draw
oops leymah draw yeah okay so let's do
one more
I'm still behind with one lost one game
what I'm trying to say two draws and one
loss maybe it gets better okay well this
is probably going to be yeah BOGO style
position and this is a good position
against the computer this is position
type in general is kind of good where
this an engine because it's very closed
so let's go b5 and see what the engine
is doing not d5 I can try c5 and
probably not
okay that's interesting yeah it's 95
something I don't think so okay so I
actually managed to provoke that g5f
okay so Bishop g7 I guess so very close
they're very close stuff hmm let's make
sure that age of seven is safe
what's now I would like to come up
clarify the situation on the Queen side
not quite sure ever how okay I can take
this bishop takes
there's some way to some way to get that
night on a six into the game
yeah you know I have to I have to
rearrange this it's just just too awful
one a6 I have to GU night b8 something
something like that is it a problem if I
do that
maybe I should cover c8 first I know it
looks terrible
this undeveloped thing kind of play but
I think it's it's what I need to do okay
this is plundering c7 that's not good I
can take now and take a one and then go
night a six again this is actually an
idea now that I managed to trade some
some stuff okay so Queen a5 is that
doing something I don't know c5 not sure
is this a threat hmm it's kind of
passive quite clearly but I don't know
if it's really a problem well if I go we
should be for computer we'll play okay
one very heavy lightly Queen the aides
intending c5 but maybe computer goes C 5
C 5 anyway hmm yeah that's let's make
that possible
I don't know yeah it's they're a big
threat there I don't see it let's just
improve a little bit c5 is this coming
if I go like b6 and back to f6 b6 and
Bishop d7 Kade I know it's very passive
but is it is it is it bad I don't know
let's try c5 immediately is the threat
it should be 75
okay that means I have to go back which
is really awful
so night over tomb you have 6 you might
just play Queen a 7 95 and this is this
is what sometimes can happen if you
really try to play this super closed
entire computer strategy you sometimes
get too passive but try to yeah try to
yeah playing a wiki but style all of the
all of the time but should be 6 so maybe
like this I'm kinda I'm still hanging on
for a little bit as I said it is not
particularly great but
yeah I cannot cannot play 97 again
I'd be five is a threat
no that's losing now right a six was bad
that the very first night a six that
really led to trouble already
yeah I have no who were just lost
no not much to do well resign if I can I
go here yeah you know what what's what
was bad here night eight six years just
the terrible move I get into trouble
from here I should do something like 9b
d7 now night f8 or so this is this is
okay really but but the way I played it
it's just bad the night is not coming
coming back in any way how do I get back
to the actual game I just I want to play
more one more play probably hear you
play with the machine
and I've got one more white game so I've
got two losses and I have two draws so
let's play a somewhat more mainstream
opening here and see what happens
what do we get NIMS Oh our Queens gambit
yeah I'm going to play the exchange
variation this is very there is solid
you just succeed okay I'm going to look
back somehow recently this age sixth
type of setup has gained some popularity
and played by a couple of good players
okay I don't really mind that trait oops
doesn't trade okay I'm taking take that
tempo h3 is generally useful okay a
computer wants to emplace e5 and I'm
going to make it a little bit more
difficult to do
so I'm just taking here happy but that
that structure them iqp position the
only thing is my queen is somewhat wrong
1 C 2 as Rupa will come to c8 that's
definitely happening
hmm where do I put it it's not so easy
to organize this position Knight c3
would like to be on d4 Knight b5 well
black will probably take and it's not
that clear what I should do here what is
a good setup
and it's it's it's actually more key for
black than I thought I thought that it
really should be some kind of advantage
but it's not it's not that apparent
really if this is the case 92 there's
even Bishop a4 it's really annoying
yeah 94 it's amazing that Bishop is kind
of unstable on YouTube
anyway it's hard to believe that this
should be bad him okay rook b8 not rooks
yet I was expecting rook c8 let's do
this okay it's going to win the temper
with who behead and now exceed okay now
I definitely I think you should move the
Queen my idea was Queen a2 is this kind
of setup
I just hope that I'm not Bishop a5 yeah
hmm that's the way to lose against the
computer I am one move blunders cannot
even go in fire because of the maid down
on c1
very very frustrating
really I cannot take one before anywhere
because rook c1 is immediately coming it
doesn't it doesn't have to recapture
even
yeah it was stupid is that okay come on
that was terrible really very bad very
bad
what did I do here that cannot be really
the I mean what should be slightly
better here but what did I do wrong
96 what did I do wrong
5 I can't get in see fire I don't really
see I don't think I can prevent it
castles you 5 yeah like it's not in bad
shape at all I mean he's pretty or it is
pretty active maybe I have to go 94 and
cover b3 as well well okay this is this
wasn't a problem really but Queen c2
maybe already is one there is no
particular hoops
and there was a computer and then this
is done without me doing it ready yeah
here Queenie - of course yeah that that
was clearly clearly that mistake Bishop
f5 is still okay but in general I rather
don't want to go there maybe two eight
who here maybe this that black is okay
so it is definitely active enough mmm
let's let's do one more I really hate to
play that badly I just wanna come on way
is that play with the comp and so let's
see let's do anti computer French is a
good anti computer opening because it
has said that close character going for
this line this is a node favorite of
mine trading of the LightSquared bishop
and then play this very close position
okay okay I really don't mind to have it
closed
aha interesting gives me d5
I don't mind dad
okay if I take it night will come to
will come to before which will probably
happen anyway the question is is it is
it a problem Queen a force is an
interesting move here but Queenie 4 will
be the answer very likely at least hmm I
wonder can i its bishop f eh this is too
provocative maybe yes but I still do it
I cannot help myself so now get what
about this screen a4 move
we need for queen bee - probably
I mean if I if I reach some kind of
endgame I'm not in bad shape here the
question is do I Richard even g5 and
then we should be serving us quite quite
decent would love to trade Queens quite
of this name
can I go yeah I have to I think I have
to do that
come on and one point I need to connect
rooks it's it's it's really unavoidable
we should be seven yeah each one but
okay if the computer takes it's not it's
not the end of the world really we can
come to you for all this is irritating
me quite a bit but let's do this night
is well placed down okay that's
interesting queen a3 maybe T X takes
rook a1 or I can play g4 I mean why not
exactly
okay 9224 is probably happening okay
okay came Queen a - maybe Queen H oh but
slightly irritating maybe
a 92 we were probably playing 92 Bishop
III I don't know saying it's the engine
it's always somewhat intimidating I
always think okay that's not blunder
stuff Bishop III here and ultimately
that that might blow up in my face if I
take each voice go through a one my
queen is really trapped it's really
trapped that term should not be
underestimated
Queen a3 is no rules
okay okay - this is a huge issue but
okay maybe I can go Queen III actually I
mean AAA discovered okay at least I have
the Queen's of the lady computers bloody
computers was that so bad for black with
white pieces misplaced you know and II
23 maybe it was I don't know just that
this simple tactic is winning the game
yeah
cannot I mean
yeah 96 unfortunately sure
it's two bones okay this is this is very
questionable technically but it is so
winning that probably it doesn't matter
I came you know the point is just it's
just it's just promoting on its own
in a bishop before okay
that I mean it's not like I had a
strategically bad position or anything
that was just interesting for example if
I have some more get Queens traded right
is just just in very bad shape but I
couldn't get it going I simply couldn't
Quincy won this this yeah okay well this
is losing then this is losing due to
that due to that stupid tactic clemency
form I don't know I don't really know
what what to say about this kind of
position okay one maybe if if this is
happening it's already kind of bad yeah
there's also this Queen a4 idea there's
a button requests the computer analysis
I can do that I really don't know this
side so let's see if the what the
computer analysis is doing
my currently is displaying some kind of
waiting like work-in-progress yeah work
in progress
yeah I really don't know I was kind of
surprised by by white going for this
structure because it is frankly speaking
just anti positional it really is but
probably not not bad enough so that I
can easily win yeah so we have Queen
Queen a to the best move was Bishop a
three years with equal play yeah Queen
a3 was quite clearly the decisive
mistake question is did could I have
done something better here computer is
no clear suggestion it gives the
position yes about equal yeah Queen if I
like the Queen a4 idea in general but
yeah it's not quite clear what I'm doing
then that was the reason why I didn't
play it I really didn't see a big point
there I don't get the Queen's off and I
don't get so quickly organized if I
manage one of the two winners have to
get Bishop e7 King D 7 and then white is
basically busted here strategically
because this is weak here I have the
better Bishop is Bishop is night those
are all bad pieces but maybe I don't get
them it's it's it's really possible not
not sure if this would have been an
improvement in the first place but
should be 7 if h4 and I'd be d5
ok maybe I have to go King b7 I mean
this is possible that I should just do
this and then intend to go Queen to a4
difficult same it's definitely
interesting this position I'd rather be
black still but it is some yeah the
thing you make one one little slip and
the engine will punish you like like it
I kept it in the game this this kind of
thing this this is something that a
human player has to see first I mean
it's not really clear that that
everybody will go will will do that
especially considering that the Queen
trait strategically is terrible but I
think it's it wins because of the tactic
yeah you have to really see that there
is this tactic I actually what I did see
is I did see that this is not a big
issue because I have a aid cupboard but
the problem is that yeah it it can take
and take on c4 ok there was a little bit
of torture by the computer maybe I can't
do better if I just do that engine a
little bit a little bit better but it
will be difficult in any case 8 plus 5
is also on the quick side but I don't
want to play for
full-length rapid game against the comp
okay well thanks for watching